bon ça peut avoir l'air
spitz
bonjour vous êtes moi je suis bien quoi
bien bien bien verbier
non j'ai pas j'ai passé sur la liste
centrale j'ai une bière la papa très
fraîche c'est normal bah écoutez je
vérifie
d'après les oreilles et les yeux on
serait sûr un petit apéro entre potes là
au nom ce pauvre est normalement ce soir
j'étais of en plus les bières si les
deux pires allez soyez sympa on n'est
qu'à 5 degrés là ça passe bon ok rentrée
allez-y mais je veux entendre personne
non mais alésien fait rentrer tout le
monde comme dans un moulin après c'est
moi qui dégustent donc dans ce corps
j'ai vraiment le mauvais rôle moi c'est
moi c'est pas ouf non plus at aidera les
là ce soir c'est juste quelques bières
ça va j'en ai excusez moi
ma mémoire va se passer mais non
champagne double champion
je retire ce que j'ai à me dire tous les
organes tout le monde à son poste il ya
de fortes chances qu'on termine lourd
est là au nom
pas vous reste un bon allez au boulot
équipe de nuit resserre les boulons
moi je trouve ça plutôt cool la soirée
peut aussi bien se terminer
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir salut vous venez de la part de
franprix c'est bien ce que je pensais
alors je viens de recevoir un message de
la langue et je confirme c'est de la
piquette ou à les y rentrer mais pas de
brûlures
les gardes à vue un café au point de se
placer en train de s'accélérer je sais
pas pourquoi non c'est pas un café c'est
pire c'est chloé son ex non mais c'est
génial
[Musique]
cerveau lâche tout c'est moi qui prend
le contrôle attendait déjà non et en
plus elle a un nouveau mec
[Applaudissements]
moi perso non là ça change pas mon
talent
un montage c'est la piste alors et ne
compte pas ça peut être pire ça peut
partir en grosses traces pour oublier je
viens à penser à un truc là on n'a pas
mangé mais nord tu es sur un type
d'actif lot mais ça fait deux heures
donc pas ouf ça veut dire que le
solitaire pilori qui est ouvert les gars
ça peut partir en couille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais allez-y pourquoi aujourd'hui
j'arrive plus à gérer moi ça devient
floue on a tous la notion du temps et
par contre eu qu'intéressant on est
devenus villardienne eyewear ap new york
une fois ce genre blige par rob white du
louvre le musée
[Musique]
vous êtes passé du temps enfin du moins
on croit l'être mais moi je trouve que
les meufs sont de plus en plus mignonnes
à cette soirée et les mecs aussi
d'ailleurs calme toi
au ralenti on n'arrive plus à gérer
ah ouais j'suis d'accord si ça continue
là ça va finir en cirrhose et la
cirrhose c'est vrai qu'ils me la tap ah
pardon désolé mais je fais ce que je
peux et les gars je suis pas le seul
responsable
et boit de l'eau
[Musique]
là j'ai tout
taub tu vises à côté là non c'est pas
moi qui contrôle l'un c'est le cerveau
pardon mais j'arrive pas à les commandes
sont inversés jeu j'arrive plus à viser
attendait mais je crois que le système
est complètement buggé en fait
ah bah non fx le miroir il doit remettre
sa vie en question là autant c'est une
vieille machine à 87 c'est normal ça
date un temps pat 9 pas de taf pas de
projet de pêche la mine croesus
ah ça y est ça repart
[Musique]
et allez les shots venus en bus au colza
achevé mois cette soirée sera sans doute
ma dernière you ça fait longtemps ça
vaut quoi j'attends qu'ils savent à wow
je commence à perdre le contrôle là j'ai
même pu quitter tous les tur entre
les gars faut que je vous les vannes à
kiev moi je vis ma meilleure life les
mecs je pensais qu'on ne pouvait plus de
béré en fait je vois ta gueule j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] l es tu rentres
[Musique]
ce champ
alerte générale tout le monde est ok
chef allait tout le monde sort
ça
moi perso plus ça sort plus ça m'arrange
j'ai moins de talent derrière
[Musique]
ok à toutes les unités tout le monde se
lève il est midi les gars je sais même
pas si je suis encore en train de battre
là je suis au rythme d'un zouk love
je crois pas le voir faire une vidange
du matin désolé c'est toujours l'impasse
et ça rentre ça sort bon je vais pas
inventer j'ai pas inventé l'eau chaude
non
bonjour salut tu fais rentrer
c'était horrible je crois qu'il faut que
j'en parle à un psy tiens d'ailleurs tub
c'est bien silencieux là tu as fini la
soirée commémore pas disons que en fin
de soirée j'ai bossé un peu des deux
avec qui
avec moi
le tombeur ou pas ça va parce qu'on peut
un
bon tout le monde parle en sérieusement
si on se faisait un petit mac do
[Musique]
je savais que ça allait vous plaire
ouais bof
[Musique]
sous acide